dans une question puis y ait
effectivement à cette ressource
d'énergie et l'évolution de nos sociétés
claire dépend comment c'est vous de la
porte
j'ai étudié de travaux comme chez leur
fille qui voit dans l'apport de
nouvelles technologies de cette
décentralisation est mise en réseau des
possibilités de trouver d'autres
solutions pour régler effectivement une
société de progrès alors on va voir
revenir à ce que j'ai évoquée au début
de cette intervention
ce qui a fait division masse des objets
que nous avons et à la cervelle fait la
conception de l'eau gèle sa diffusion
c'est une affaire d'énergie le fait
qu'aujourd'hui on est juste ça ça vous
rend encore plus d'énergie que le verre
on est venu partager sur un an tu m as
enfin pourtant dépassé d'ordinateur
central 2 milliards a simplement imagine
mieux mais ça c'est une donne deux sur
200 personnes pour le fabriquer une
utilisation supériorité il dote de surf
par personne pour le faire payer la rose
de l'empreinte carbone des français
entre 1990 et 2010 c'est à dire la
contrepartie de la consommation des
français et pour les deux tiers du a5 ou
délit
l'ajout des technologies d'information
laval nouvelle et ses empreintes carbone
des français les échos bambou jusqu'à
maintenant la démocratisation des usages
pour aller avec le mp et récuse
d'énergie la voiture d'aujourd'hui est
vachement plus efficace que la voiture
est à 50 ans mais consomment pour plus
de pétrole en livre audio plus de dire
justement parce que efficace si
aujourd'hui on pouvait en attendant je
vais la consommation globale des avions
sont considérablement inférieur donc le
la diffusion intervient alors maintenant
que j'y suis resté dix ont décentraliser
les harraga problème je pense qu'une se
trouvent deux fois je pense qu'une seule
seconde une première fois et ça renvoie
la question qui a été posée buteur
parce que face à des problèmes globaux
tous ne veulent pas étirer un échelon
régional
ça c'est la première ronde d'hier
gouvernance locale puisque betty foule
je pense que oui et non je pense que
d'éditer les langues nationales sur la
taille des carottes vous vous trouvez au
marché les grilles
par contre je pense que sur tous les
marchés
par contre je pense que dit il n'y a
plus de place pour un pilotage national
d investissement partagé entre tottenham
et je vais prendre un exemple très
caustique qui se lit il existe des
différences entre temps la difficulté du
scion oui larmes allongement des temps
de les citer si vous passez le nucléaire
aux panneaux solaires pour produire la
même quantité d'électricité vous avez
besoin de 50 à 100 euros pour les autres
je ne crois pas que ça soit de nature en
vous permettre de gérer plus facilement
un problème on y est contraint les
dirigeants de le faire en vous donc je
pense que rifkin sa théorie elle est
tout à fait entier tomic
par contre la clé des champs pour 650
euros chambre mais il est enfin en fait
tu devras magasin parce que vous avez du
serveur de business convenablement comme
les autres c'est ça est derrière jamais
derrière le préparer en vue des séries
de problèmes
donc je vois la décence et la pollution
électrique c'est d'étudier le vent
capitaux
306 veut dire si françois lambert que si
vous avez 100 digard a dénoncé et bien
si vous les centraliser la production
était paralysée grand format l'horreur
par contre on descend ça y est
farouchement électrique
il ya des pertes au rythme lent de chez
les centrales sont pas toujours à
proximité des productions de bon sens
vous traversez la france sur le codage
des deux longueurs au réveil
heureusement pour un certain nombre de
gens devront donc avant qu'on sent dans
ce nouveau bon sens aurait fait
qu'acheter après il faut savoir les
moyens d'y décentralisée passé et
certaines quantités et plus les
augmenter vous avez un truc on a veillé
à savoir ce qu'on injecte et sur le
réseau sont en basse tension soir 80
monuments et décentralisé il faut faire
monter la tension
le moment où j'étais et une fois vous
avez indiquent les combats débutent et
si vous commencez un vga chez eux devant
la tasmanie franchement ça coulait
largement droit parce que justement ça
fait trop ou telle intention et à ce
moment il nous parle des moyens donc le
foie le vaux bien comprendre mieux se
vendre il doit être compatible avec les
sociétés en résistance structurelle et
je pense que ce qu'ils proposent c'est
justement quelque chose qui correspond à
une société en france un quart des
jeunes